israel ha construido más de 30
asentamientos judíos en los altos del
golán la vasta meseta que separa al país
de su vecina siria tiene aproximadamente
18 veces el tamaño de parís israel
confiscó la mayor parte de los altos del
golán decir ya en la guerra de los seis
días de 1967 considerado por israel como
una importante zona de amortiguación con
su vecino ambos países valoran la región
por su gran altitud lo que la convierte
en un punto de vigilancia estratégico
siria intentó recuperar los altos del
golán durante la guerra árabe-israelí de
1973 pero fracasó al año siguiente los
dos países firmaron el acuerdo de
separación poniendo fin al conflicto las
fuerzas de paz de la onu han patrullado
a lo largo de la llamada línea púrpura
desde entonces en 1981 israel declaró la
anexión de dos tercios de los altos del
golán en un movimiento considerado
ilegal según el derecho internacional
esto cambió en 2019 cuando la
administración del presidente de eeuu
donald trump reconoció oficialmente el
reclamo de la soberanía de israel sobre
partes de la región
el presidente de trump es un gran amigo
de nuestro estado un líder que ha hecho
cosas que no se hicieron anteriormente y
que deberían haberse hecho en nombre de
la justicia y la verdad
damasco todavía quiere recuperar el
territorio y las escaramuzas fronterizas
estallan esporádicamente los dos países
han tenido negociaciones intermitentes
desde los años 90 antes de que llegaran
a su fin cuando estalló la guerra civil
en siria hoy además de su importancia
geográfica los altos del golán ofrecen
tierra fértil y es una fuente clave de
agua para israel en una región árida